it's my pleasure to introduce to you
tonight our speaker Daniel M Kimmel my
name is Michele Reed I'm a sophomore
here at Hillsdale College studying
philosophy and religion I'm from Walker
Michigan Daniel M Kimmel is the past
president of the Boston society of Film
Critics and founding co-chair of the
Boston Online Film Critics Association
mr. Kimmel has taught film and media
courses at Suffolk University and
Emerson College his reviews appeared in
the Wurster telegram and Gazette for
many years and can now be found at North
Shore Movies net mr. Kimmel has written
on the histories of Fox TV and
DreamWorks a recipient of the Skylark
Award for the New England
science-fiction Association he was also
nominated for the Hugo Award for the
book jar jar binks must die and other
observations about science fiction
movies he is also the author of Shh it's
a secret
a novel about aliens Hollywood and the
bartenders guide time on my hands my
misadventures in time travel and I'll
have what she's having
behind the scenes of the great romantic
comedies please join me in welcoming
Daniel M Kimmel
[Applause]
all right well thanks it's great to be
back here I was here four years ago and
I said I would love to come back and
speak again but don't ever invite me to
speak on Oscar night that's that's my
Super Bowl that's but but not a problem
this year
all right so tonight my topic is the
comedy of Billy Wilder and when the
American Film Institute put together a
list of the funniest movies of all time
in 2000 some like a hot caiman is number
one now that's a tall order the funniest
comedy ever made when I was teaching
film which I did for about 25 years I
had the same problem with Citizen Kane
not as the funniest movie ever made but
how could any film live up to the
reputation of the greatest movie ever
made especially if it was in black and
white and I and the kids didn't know
anybody who was in it so let's begin by
saying that such a lists are interesting
especially for helping to recommend
films that you might not have seen but
the ranking themselves are relatively
unimportant now I've taught Billy Wilder
films and in fact have used all of the
films you're screening this week they
are certainly four of his best and
what's fascinating about Wilder to me is
that he excelled at both comedy and
drama and one can find instances of his
sardonic humor in all of his films in
spotlighting his comedy my first
inclination was to go through all of his
movies and celebrate them all then I
woke up and realized that for the
students here some like it hot maybe the
first Billy Wilder comedy you've ever
seen my analyzing the 7-year itch or
Merle adduce might be brilliant and
incisive but it might as well be in
Greek for people who've never seen them
and of course the students here are
studying Latin so that wouldn't have
helped
so I'll be citing examples from his
other movies but I've decided to take a
different approach using some like it
hot as our basis I want to give you the
tools so that you can go off on your own
and watch his other movies with some
degree of expertise and you should as I
used to tell my students you don't walk
into a museum and say just show me the
new paintings right it's like no I don't
need to see that Rembrandt and Picasso
so just what did you get last week that
we've got with Netflix and Amazon and
Hulu and Turner Classic Movies not to
mention our libraries you have access to
more than a century of cinema when I was
a college student I would be scanning
there they don't even exist anymore the
revival houses the theaters showing
classic movies is there a chance some
movie I've always wanted to see could be
showing up or on The Late Late Show at
2:00 in the morning now no matter you
know what's your age and I know it's not
just students here tonight you have the
unprecedented ability to explore the
movies as never before in history you
can look at films in a variety of ways
when they were made what genre they are
what country they came from or following
the career of a particular star but when
you have a director with a strong point
of view what the French critics referred
to as an auteur it's a fancy word for
author going through the films of the
directors career can be illuminating
think of Alfred Hitchcock or Martin
Scorsese or Woody Allen when you look at
their body of work you discover the
imprint that makes their films easily
distinguishable from the works of others
now the summer after I graduated from
the University of Rochester in upstate
New York I had one of the most unusual
jobs I've ever had I was working as a
security guard at ABC and I have a great
story about that which I'm not going to
tell you now but asked me at the
later I had tuesdays and wednesdays off
and by chance a a place i didn't even
know if it exists anymore the carnegie
hall cinema in new york city was doing a
series that summer of the films of billy
wilder and so every week i got to attend
a billy wilder double feature and i
began to notice things that i might not
have picked up on if i had been seeing
the films separately or spread out over
time i
since read a great deal about Wilders
films including the wonderful book
conversations with wilder which was done
by the filmmaker cameron crowe himself a
great fan of wilder indeed crowe had
hoped to cast wilder as the asian to
appears in a flashback as the mentor to
Jerry Maguire but Wilder didn't want to
appear in front of the camera and that
might be a good place for us to start
Wilder as you no doubt have learned by
now was Austrian by birth and did his
first work in the movies in Germany and
France he came to the United States
through a complicated process that had
him leave the United States and live for
a short while in Mexico and then
re-entered the United States and a
famous anecdote he told the immigration
official that he wanted to go to
Hollywood and make movies and the
official approving his application told
him make good ones I think he lived up
to that so like other immigrants Wilder
his first job was to acquire a fin of a
fluency in American English and for
those of us born here this scenes second
nature but English is a peculiar
language and not always easy to master
the wilder did it seems he was always
self-conscious about it he his English
was a very colloquial English he picked
it up from listening to the radio
reading comic strips and throughout his
career when it came time to write a
script he always preferred to work with
one or more writers you don't see any
scripts that are just by Billy Wilder
it's always for example with one of his
two most famous partners one of them was
Charles Brackett who you've heard about
with whom he did Sunset Boulevard among
many other films and the other famous
partner that he had a long partnership
with was IAL diamonds with whom he did
some like a hot and the apartments among
many other films
now both Brackett and diamond did do
some work on their own Brackett is here
you heard the other night was so
appalled by the storyline of Double
Indemnity that Wilder ended up doing
most of the work with Raymond Chandler
because Brackett really didn't want to
participate in it Wilder was not an easy
person to work with as a writer
especially if you had a thin skin when
George Axelrod collaborated with him on
the 7-year itch Axelrod brought a
manuscript with him which was a copy of
his own hit Broadway play and he figured
they would be using that to adapt into
the the movie version and he told Wilder
here's a copy of my play and Wilder
replied good we could use it as a
doorstop Ernest Lehman was another
collaborator of a Wilder they did they
did the script for Sabrina
now Lehman would also have a long and
distinguished career but this was fairly
early on and working with Wilder on
Sabrina was meant working on a set where
there was a lot of tension
Humphrey Bogart was a Warner Brothers
star working at Paramount for the first
time and it was very uncomfortable
because Wilder and his co-stars Audrey
Hepburn and William Holden were
paramount stars and so Bogart felt like
the odd man out to make it a little more
complicated the story involved Hepburn
as the chauffeurs daughter having a
crush on the dashing son of her father's
boss played by William Holden and yet
having to end up with the older brother
played by Humphrey Bogart that
the plot behind the camera she was
having an affair with Liam Holden so it
was a very tense set and at one point
London Lehman ended up having a nervous
collapse and and the doctor ordered him
to stay away from the set and go home
and several days bed rest and just not
work on the movie on the doctor's last
visit where he pronounced Lehmann cured
and ready to go back to work as he left
he said oh and you can tell mr. Wilder
he can come out of the closet now Wilder
had been hiding in the closet so the
doctor wouldn't see him because he
couldn't imagine making any changes on
the script without working with his
collaborator with diamonds diamonds real
real name was Isadora he was known as
Izzy diamond the AL was an affectation
he thought it made him look fancier true
and diamond he gave an additional credit
not simply co-writer he was also an
associate producer and he whatever said
diamond got this credit because he was
the only one willing to associate with
the producer who was Wilder in fact what
it meant was that diamond had the right
to be on the set which was highly
unusual for writers of that era usually
they turned in the script and that was
the last I had to do with it or that you
know they might be asked for rewrites
but actually being on the set seeing the
shooting interacting with the actors
this was not done and Wilder wanted his
collaborator there for Wilder the script
always came first
and it was not simply because they
couldn't shoot blank pages because he
had started out as a screenwriter this
is where he created his movies among his
early credits before he became a
director where such movies as ninotchka
and ball of fire however while he
revered Ernst Lubitsch the director of
ninotchka he was less enthusiastic about
at least some of the other directors who
filmed his scripts and so he decided he
needed to direct himself because of
these other directors they would let the
actors ad-lib or they would make changes
on the set and Wilder felt no I'm ganna
do the script this is the film you need
to make so he began in 1942 directing
with a movie called the major in the
minor he was lucky and this is well you
want you want a series you could do in
the future
preston sturges was another top comedy
writer who in 1940 became a director and
as a result of his success and he was
one of the top comedy directors of the
1940s other writers started saying you
know we would like to direct to John
Huston was another one Joseph mankiewicz
and Billy Wilder
so for Wilder if he felt directing was
the way to protect the words on the page
when you watch a Wilder movie you have
to listen every word has been chosen
with care and if the actor decided to
improvise or change the dialogue and
some did Wilder would make them do it
again this afternoon those of you who
watched some like it hot there's a whole
little running joke about Type O blood
it's a it's just a little minor thing
but you better say Type O or the joke
doesn't work and so there were all sorts
of little things like that that he would
plant in the script that it had to be
done just right so let's take a deeper
look at some like a hot while during
Diamond took the plot from a story that
had already been made into films in
France and Germany under the title
fanfares of love in those films two
musicians
disguise themselves to perform in
various bands they're basically down on
their luck musicians who they get
dressed up as gypsies or as women or the
you know just different things to get
into a band to get a job while during
time and through that out what they
liked was the idea of two men who for
some reason have to dress up as women
and perform in an all-girls band
and they said all right now we had a
concept what are we gonna do with it and
diamond pointed out that when the
classic American cross-dressing play the
classic comedy the American stage
Charlie's ands was ever performed it was
almost always performed in period and
diamond said the reason for that is that
if everybody in the play is in period
costume then the two guys dressed as
women are just two more characters in
funny costumes and so they decided we
need to do this in period so then they
had to decide what time period they set
the story in and they decided on
prohibition which provided them with a
plot of why these characters had to
dress up as women they had witnessed the
st. Valentine's Day Massacre and they
were on the run from the mob now if
you're familiar with Wilders other
movies do you see that this notion of
disguise or and changing or hiding
identities is something that occurs
again and again in the major and the
minor Ginger Rogers an adult woman has
to pretend she's a young girl and hide
out at a girls school in Double
Indemnity both the perpetrators of the
murder have hidden agendas even from
each other in Stalag 17 said anna german
prisoner of war camp one of the captives
is actually a german spy in our lab
deuce jack lemmon pretends to be a
British gentleman so he can prevent Alma
played by Shirley MacLaine from
prostituting herself in the fortune
cookie Walter Matthau his lawyer gets
his brother-in-law Jack Lemmon to
pretend that his injuries are much more
serious so that they can scan the
insurance company you see the pattern
here and some like a hot there are
multiple layers of disguise Tony Curtis
plays three characters as Joe he's the
alpha male he the brash guy who pushes
his friend Gerry around gets up the hock
their coats in the middle of a Chicago
winter and is clearly the sort of
lowlife who has been sugars typical
boyfriend
notice that when he becomes Josephine he
becomes the opposite Josephine is
refined and demure a proper young lady
or at least one who would travel with an
all-girls band as part of her made-up
biography she even claims to have
studied in a conservatory and as we
later find out without really
understanding what that means there now
compare that with Gerry as Gerry he's a
patsy yet when he gets into dread
something happens first of all notice
he's not Geraldine he rejects that he
becomes Daphne and Daphne is a hot
ticket she slaps her base she had she's
brash the way he never was as Gerry his
big scene with sugar in the upper berth
of the Train shows a confidence in the
surprises that he imagines that will
soon be uncovered and he reverts to jury
only when the arrival of the other women
in the band make it likely that his
secret is going to be revealed now Joe
has a third identity as shale-oil jr.
while there ask Curtis if he could
affect the Boston accent because he said
she'll junior has to sound different
from from Joe and from Josephine Curtis
on his own I'm with Wilders permission
decided he was going to go with a Cary
Grant voice and this has layers of
meaning if are in a Wilder film Wilder
had always wanted to work with Cary
Grant and Cary Grant was you know
experienced at comedy and forests and
for some reason he liked Wilder they
were if they were friendly he backed out
a to Wilder films he was supposed to be
in he was supposed to have the Humphrey
Bogart role in Sabrina and he was
supposed to have the Gary Cooper part
and love in the afternoon and in both
cases he decided he didn't want to do it
so it also leads to the wonderful moment
with jury mocks him by imitating him
imitating the Cary Grant voice that
going nobody talks like that
and Shell Oil Junior is curtis's most
interesting incarnation in the film he's
hot for sugar we know that but having
learned how she's been hurt by people
just like him while he was Josephine
he's now taking a different tack
pretending to be impotent or at the very
least a sexual so that sugar is put at
the position of having to seduce him and
the sugar too has to take on another
identity instead of the hapless victim
that we've come to know so far she
becomes the aggressor going after sho
oil with a confidence we haven't seen in
her earlier now we can go on and on and
find other examples of people assuming
alternate identities from the brassy
bandleader who presents herself is sweet
sue and the rowdy musicians who are the
society Syncopators to spats Colombo who
shows up for a mob meet that's being
presented as the Friends of the Italian
opera since this is a theme that recurs
in so many Wilder films it's natural to
ask why now I don't want to spoil the
joke by getting too serious and
explaining it
however it's part of the reason the film
resonates and I was very pleased that
apparently still resonates today both
Jerry and Joe get to explore other
aspects of their personalities indeed
the opposite of who they ordinarily are
by donning drag when they finally revert
to their male identities at the end of
the film there are different people as a
result Joe confesses to sugar who he
really is
and will presumably treat her
differently now that he's come to see
how his past romantic flings you know
have been experienced from the female
side as for Jerry who sets up Osgood
with with the film's immortal closing
line which which I'll get back to think
about how he starts that that that last
scene by reverting to his passive
personality and explaining why they
can't get married
I smoke I can never have children and by
the end he's boldly asserted himself as
jure taking off his wig of going I'm a
man you know that's that's a big change
for this character now don't stick
together here we go
now I've mentioned how Wilder learned
English from very colloquial sources
like comic strips and radio programs
Wilder was also a very cultured person
who put together a famously impressive
personal collection of art he was a
serious art collector but in his films
he was making pop-culture references
long before that became a Hollywood
cliché when Ginger Rogers arrives at the
girls Academy and the major and the
minor a row of teen girls turned to her
all sporting the peekaboo hairstyle that
it was made famous by 1940s actress
Veronica Lake Sunset Boulevard of course
is filled with movie references some
that were clearly in jokes one that I'll
point out that may have eluded you like
having Jayne Livingston and Ray Evans at
the piano of a New Year's party leading
a group singing the hit song buttons and
bows the reason that's an in-joke is
that Livingston and Evan were the ones
who wrote that song they were playing
themselves and the apartment Baxter
you'll see this tomorrow invites Fran to
the then hit Broadway show The Music Man
in the original script this was going to
be the sound of music but then wilder an
Austrian Jew who would lost family in
the Holocaust was in New York for the
location shooting and got tickets for
The Sound of Music
and was appalled what he saw singing and
dance and singing and dancing Nazi this
is years before the producers and he
changed the script so they went to the
music man instead some like it hot is
also filled with several references to
classic gangster films of the 1930s but
if you don't know the film's
you might not get the jokes so I'll be
now point them out to you for those of
you who don't know the classic gangster
films the casting of George Raft and Pat
O'Brien as spats and the the police
detective is part of it raft had played
several gangster roles in the 30s and
40s and Pat O'Brien had played opposite
James Cagney and one of the great
gangster films angels with dirty faces
then there's the moment when raft
arrives of the hotel and has to check
his guns and there's a guy standing in
there flipping a coin in the air and
raft is annoyed he grabs the coin he
said where'd you pick up that cheap
trick well he learned it from George
Raft of the 1932 movie Scarface where
that was RAF's signature gesture in
Scarface and even better who was the guy
flipping the coin it's Edward G Robinson
jr. Edward G Robertson every we saw him
and Double Indemnity but his first great
role was his little Caesar and then
there's the top it off there's the
moment at the banquet where one of
Speck's
henchmen says something stupid you know
we was in Rigoletto with you boss and
and what is spats know he picks up half
a grapefruit because he's gonna hit him
in the face with it and if you know the
James Cagney movie Public Enemy which is
the movie that made Cagney a star one of
the most notorious and and and shocking
scenes to 1932 audiences was when Cagney
picks up a half a grapefruit and
actually slaps Mae Marsh in the face
with it all audiences in 1959 would have
been much more likely to recognize these
references and it demonstrated to them
that Wilder lived in the same world we
did sharing the same movies and other
bits of pop-culture as the rest of us
now another element of wildest comedies
and dramas at their best is that he was
always pushing the envelope sometimes he
would be accused of bad taste which i
think is unfair but he would take on
subjects and themes that other
filmmakers felt couldn't be
done double indemnity when the novel
came out was sent to the production code
office and they and the answer came back
no way no how this cannot be filmed
Wilder figured out a way to tell this
story of adultery and murder within the
confines of the production code then he
when he did the Lost Weekend if you look
at how movie drunks were portrayed prior
to the Lost Weekend
they were comic figures like the guy in
some like ad hoc who wants another cup
of coffee that was the typical movie
drunk he does a serious movie about
alcoholism that even has a scene with
Ray Milland combating delirium tremens
and the film was a hit and Malayan won
an Oscar the frothy romantic comedy
sabrina has a scene where the ingenue
played by Audrey Hepburn attempts to
commit suicide Sunset Boulevard which
also has attempted suicide was a movie
narrated by a corpse telling how he
became a kept man to a much older woman
the 7-year itch required a number of
changes from the stage play but was
still about a married man tempted to
have a fling while the apartment which
will see tomorrow which one wilder three
Oscars for Best Picture Best Director
and Sharon with Izzy diamond for Best
Screenplay was about a man advancing his
career by loaning his bed to his
unscrupulous superiors this was all
pretty tough stuff and Wilder did it and
he did it in a ways that audiences could
accept what Wilde I had a great run and
I'm partial to some of his later films
like one two three and the fortune
cookie but the problem with some of the
movies after the early 60s is that he
was no longer ahead of the curve
he was now trying to catch up and and
their audiences were ahead of him and
that led to eventually his unfortunate
final film buddy-buddy where he it just
fails it's just like the audience is so
far beyond where he is it's it's
unfortunate that you know he
didn't get to make a better final film
but that we have what we have
however some like it hot represents
Billy Wilder at the very top of his game
some would say the apartment some might
have other favorites but this is one of
his best and this is a movie about
sexual and gender identity that was
years ahead of its time one can see why
the Legion of decency and other groups
was up in arms about this film with it's
casual attitudes toward sex it's look at
power relationships between men and
women and a performance by Monroe that
was unbelievably hard to get but maybe
the pinnacle of her career now there
were many stories about how difficult
she was to work with on the film they
wanted she was really the reason the
film got made because they needed a big
star and she was the big star that
allowed him to cast Tony Curtis and Jack
Lemmon who were rising stars but they
were not of her caliber at that point in
their careers they wanted to make her
feel welcome she had worked with Wilder
on seven-year itch and they said we're
gonna throw a big party to welcome her
to the production cocktails I think were
at 6:00 and dinner was at 7:30 and she
and her husband Arthur Miller the
playwright showed up after 10 o'clock
this was very typical for Monroe all
through this from you hurt that's all my
story about about where's the Bourbon
but he saved the punch line for me the
second day as they're doing take a have
to take now second day of where's the
Bourbon at one point Wilder says it's
okay we'll get it and she looked at him
and goes get what she had no clue that
she was being the problem here now I
want to be fair to Monroe because there
were some things that she did
brilliantly here the scene where she
meets Shell Oil Jr on the beach they
were dreading shooting that scene it was
an outdoor scene there was so many
things that could go wrong
she got it in one take while there was
also open to suggestions from actors
and she pushed to have the film done in
color she was not she had done black and
white early in her career she felt she
looked better in color I wouldn't argue
with that but he showed her the tests of
Jack Lemmon and Tony Curtis in their
heavy makeup and for the film and
lighting at the time they looked like
the Frankenstein monster and they were
they were greeting it was terrible and
she said great we have to shoot this in
black and white but she also said to him
I don't have an entrance I just like
walk into the film I'm the star I need
an entrance and he said you know you're
right
and so that scene when she's coming down
the train platform and the the steam
shoots out of the trailer she gives that
little jump and wiggle that was her
entrance that was added at her behest
and he said she was right she she's the
star she needs a moment to come into the
film and it also has Jack lemons get a
great response it's it's like jello on
Springs it's a whole different sex
Wilder was exasperated and after this
film he said he spoke to his
psychiatrist and his accountant and they
both said he's too rich and he's too old
to go through that again and and there
was some exchange of words between him
and Arthur Miller but in the in the end
Wilder had to acknowledge that there was
something she had a special quality and
I love this quote he goes now my aunt
Minnie would always be punctual and
never hold up production but who would
pay to see my aunt Minnie yes this is a
movie where as I said Joe and Jerry
become better men B by becoming women
with the most macho character wearing
spats and when gay marriage in 1959 is
embraced with the line nobody's perfect
now several wilder films have memorable
lines because I've you know he started
with the script it was about the words
so Sunset Boulevard is chock full of
famous lines including the you know that
the line at the end all right I'm ready
for my
close-up mr. DeMille and as you'll see
tomorrow in the apartment and I'm not
even going to tell you what the line
means you're gonna just have to watch
the movie shut up and deal and then then
there's a line from the major in the
minor that may have been wilder and may
have been Robert Benchley who delivered
the line but it's a great line he says
to Ginger Rogers coming in out of the
pouring rain why did you get out of that
wet coated into a dry martini but
perhaps the most famous single line from
any Wilder film is well nobody's perfect
and interestingly over the years and
while there was interviewed many times
he would be asked so who came up with
this idea or who came up with that idea
and we and he he would not take credit
for himself it was always we did it
together it's our script it was it was
Oh as a matter of fact when he and
diamond won the Oscar for screenplay for
the apartment there thank you speeches
were very brief Thank You mr. Wilder
thank you mr. diamond that was how he
felt about his screenwriting
collaborators yet always Wilder insisted
that credit had to be given for nobody's
perfect and he insisted the credit coded
Dimond it was a Friday afternoon they
weren't sure what and what the end of
the film was going to be and diamond
came up with well nobody's perfect and
Wilder wasn't convinced and he said but
look all right it's Friday afternoon we
got the weekend to think about it maybe
we'll come up with something better by
Monday well by Monday neither of them
had a better solution and so they went
with it and when they had the first test
screening of the film remember now AFI
says it's the funniest comedy ever made
the way they would do these test
screenings in in Hollywood is there
would be some theater say on a Saturday
night here's our main attraction stick
around for us a free sneak preview of an
upcoming film and when the house lights
came up after the first screening of
some like it hot
nobody left the film died one person
left and was the television personality
Steve Allen who came up the aisle and
saw Wilders and this is a great film
they think about what went wrong the
studio somebody brilliantly added this
as a double feature to Tennessee
Williams potboiler about homosexuality
and cannibalism suddenly last summer has
to be the worst double feature in
history when they tested it again with a
more appropriate film audiences roared
when they were primed for a comedy they
got it now
some time later Wilder would be asked in
interviews of all your movies you made
somebody great movies what's your
favorite and he mentioned some like in
hot as one of his favorite films and the
interviewers were often surprised really
some like a hot nut not one of your more
serious films like Double Indemnity or
The Lost Weekend and his answer was well
they're nice films but I didn't have a
piece of the gross now this week you've
having a chance to see for Billy
Wilder's very best films and I've taught
them all and when I did a class that
focused in part of his career I include
in them all he was a very special
talents who moved easily between comedy
and drama bringing serious moments to
comedies like some like it hot in the
apartment and comic moments to serious
films like Double Indemnity and Sunset
Boulevard
so before I know we're gonna have time
for questions but I want to close my
formal remarks on a personal note my
daughter is 21 and when she was much
younger I could influence her taste by
introducing her to various movies and I
especially when she was a little kid I
would show her slapstick comedies by
Charlie Chaplin and Buster Keaton along
with many other films and as an adult
and and the daughter of a critic you you
could even though she wants to be a high
school biology teacher
she you can imagine she has her own very
strong opinions she's my daughter what I
love the fact that she still loves
Keaton and Chaplin but when she and and
she introduces them to her friends and
sometime gets very forceful about it
but her favorite movie and I had no no
reason to push this as the film that she
should she should make her favorite he's
some like it hot and whenever she starts
dating somebody new a turning point in
the relationship is when she gets him to
watch some like it hot if he likes it he
may be promoted to boyfriend if he
doesn't he's history I would like to
believe that somehow Wilder knows his
films have endured thank you
[Applause]
alright there's the person with the
microphone thank you mr. Kimmel has
agreed to sign copies of his book I'll
have what she's having behind the scenes
of the great romantic comedies directly
following the lecture outside of
Phillips auditorium we now have time for
a few questions please raise your hand
and a microphone will be brought to you
was it Marilyn Monroe's singing in the
movies
she sang another film she was in
Gentlemen Prefer Blondes and there's no
business like show business yes that
there was definitely her singing and I
loved her performances and this
especially that that last song in which
it which is really poignant yeah she
could she could sing our tables
wondering how Orry Kelly's gowns on
Marilyn Monroe passed the code
[Laughter]
orry-kelly was the designer for this
film and some of those outfits yeah
that's like right up against the
production code that was the reason that
the some of the the groups that were you
know like the Legion of decency they
were concerned about morality in the
movies found that was one of the
elements they found shocking I mean some
of those outfits look like they were
painted on and and I understand there
would sometimes be problems in the
projection booth where pieces of film
would disappear and after it played at a
particular theater there is there's a
story I'm gonna have to clean this up
because this is a family audience here
but she Marilyn Rowe comes to the set
one day and she's looking at the outfits
that have been designed for Lemon and
Curtis and she decides that she wants
one of them for herself now she I think
she had a production credit on the film
she had more clout than Curtis or lemon
on the
and if she wanted that outfit she was
gonna wear that outfit and orry-kelly
couldn't resist giving her a little
dignity and again like I said I'm
cleaning this up a little bit already
Kelly sisters as you know tony has a
nicer touch than you do and she goes
yeah well he doesn't have these if you'd
open up her blouse and he had to admit
no he didn't thank you for a very
engaging in an informative lecture today
I was thinking of another one that
considered one of the best comedies ever
made and Tootsie the same thing but
instead of trying to evade being
murdered by the mob he's just trying to
make a living as an actor and he can't
do it
he's he's considered he's too difficult
to work with but therefore he does it
and becomes he emits becomes a better
man because of doing that I was the
parallels from that if Tootsie Tootsie
is clearly a descendant of some like it
hot I haven't I haven't seen it in a
number of years but yes I when I when I
was writing this and I got this you know
became a better man by being a woman I
remembered too Hoffman having that line
in Tootsie yeah crap but I wonder if
Tootsie would have been made but for
some like it hot like I said okay and
and worth noting is that the and I'm not
up on the technical stuff the lighting
the lenses the film though all the
technology of filming had so advanced
from 1958 to Tootsie I think is 81 82 83
somewhere around there that they could
shoot it in color and and Hoffman did
not look grotesque when he was dressed
up in his female persona
we had the reference to Marilyn Monroe's
outfit but it seemed like there are so
many other references in the film you
know in the cross-dressing and the
sexual ambiguities and some of the
situations it almost seemed like Billy
Wilder and his collaborator we're trying
to see exactly what the limit was the
producers guild to allow them to make
the film with was this more poking fun
at it also
well what yet one thing you should
understand is this was born out I think
where one of the other speakers at this
point Wilder is now basically with the
marish Brothers they're an independent
production company that are releasing
through United Artists and so they had
more freedom than he had at Paramount
when he was you know he was under studio
rule they still had to obey the
production code and so there were limits
to just how far he could go but he I
think he had a much more creative leeway
when he was working with mirrors than
when he was working under the studio
system you know he had he had more
control over it and and clearly they're
they're playing with all sorts of things
I mean no Tony Curtis in drag kissing
mara Monroe is just like you know
mind-bending on so many different levels
you know I mean we know it's a guy
kissing a girl but you know immediate
you know what's a sweet Sue's reaction
is Bienstock because what's what's going
on up there there's all sorts of you
know button-pushing going on
I lost the thought I if I come back to
it I'll refer to it but yeah say yeah
but you're right here they're doing all
sorts of things with with with with
gender roles with sexual power
relationships and they're deliberately I
mean that's what that's the real subtext
of the film is what's going on there
I mean look at how Gerry Jimmy Joe Joe
and the Tony Curtis character is a
womanizer and when he's dressed up as
Josephine what happens that obnoxious
bellboy keeps hitting
on him you know and now he's seeing how
the other half lives you know and by the
same token and this is very I think it's
something that it's actually makes the
film resonate today is when we're Jack
Lemmon goes I can't believe this guy
pinched me in the elevator
look at me because oh it's like they'll
pitch anything wearing a dress you know
and it's like it's like waving a flag in
front of a bull and you know what with
all this talk about sexual harassment
today that you know it's like these two
guys are just discovering how the other
half really lives we're just like my old
classes I just stunned them into silence
not good we have another question I just
want to say how much I enjoyed I'll have
what she's having and if any of your
movie buffs you will love this book it's
just fun it's factual it's just
thoroughly enjoyable and I thank you for
that oh thank you thank you
[Applause]